bonjour bienvenue à la semaine verte en
train de plus en plus avec du vin
produit localement que ce soit au québec
en ontario ou en colombie britannique
et pour répondre à la demande les
vignerons plan des vignes à vitesse
grand v
mais avec ces nouvelles vignes viennent
parfois des virus
le domaine saint jacques à saint jacques
le mineur en montérégie est en pleine
expansion
les travailleurs agricoles plantes des
centaines de nouveaux pieds de vigne les
rénovation et agrandissement vont bon
train en quatre ans la production du
vignoble a presque doublé
plus on vend plus de gens viennent nous
visiter et plus ça avance plus il
demande plus de demandes plus grand
notre pression donc c'est un beau c'est
un beau sac vicieux mais on est dans un
cercle vicieux actuelle on fournira
jamais la demande pour 30
depuis quelques années le vigneron
privilégie la plantation de vitesse
vinifera ces variétés européennes sont à
la base de la fabrication des vins les
plus appréciés dans le monde comme les
cabernets sauvignons les pinot noir et
chardonnay ou les rieslings
[Musique]
traditionnellement on ne cultivait pas
de vitis vinifera au québec
mais depuis deux ans les superficies de
cette variété de vigne ont doublé dans
la province
elles représentent désormais 10 % les
cultures
ce subite engouement inquiète ce
spécialiste des maladies de la vigne
faudrait juste que la transition se
fasse tranquillement on veut pas d'un
seul coup shift et vert mais vitis
vinifera l'ontario l'a fait l'ebit s'est
aussi a fait beaucoup ce passage des bus
tice vinifera regarde les problématiques
de virus dans ces virus ne sont pas
dangereux pour la santé humaine
mais pour celles des plans le plus
commun c'est celui de l'enroulement de
la vigne il provoque l'enroulement des
feuilles et affectent la grosseur des
grappes qui sont plus petites que la
normale
il y a aussi le virus de la tache rose
il provoque une décoloration de la
feuille et empêche les raisins de mûrir
suffisamment pour donner le taux de
sucre nécessaires à la fabrication du
vin en termes de virus le problème
majeur c'est que ya pas de ya pas de
méthode curatif une fois que ton plan
est infectée ou pas les guérés n'y a pas
comme des pesticides qui vont permettre
de réduire la maladie un rapport c'est
en ontario ont produit le plus de 20 au
canada une bonne partie de l'industrie
est située dans la vallée du niagara au
bord du lac ontario
c'est u seek harald ciel un montréalais
d'origine a fondé edun bench à
belleville en 2003
son vignoble produit principalement du
pinot noir du chardonnay et du racing
[Musique]
d'aproz c'est vraiment un approche de
terroir nous et sur la frontière nord de
la région viticole
alors il est fausse il faut faire en
sorte que la vigne soit vraiment la
santé pour arriver à un très bon taux de
sucre et de maturité pour faire des vins
de qualité mais les vignobles de la
province sont aux prises avec une
épidémie de virus depuis cinq ans
[Musique]
il n'est pas rare que les vignerons
observe des scènes comme celle ci dans
son entourage des vignes noirâtre
complètement desséchées alors c'est des
vignes qui ont eu le virus est allé les
gens les ont arrosés avec un herbicide
pour les tuer
et cette année immonde a lâché puis
c'est dans une année ou deux années il
montre replanter de bellevue son
vignoble aussi a été affectée
[Musique]
quatre acteurs de ces plants de vigne on
doit être arrachée parce qu'ils étaient
atteints du virus de l'attachement
[Musique]
il va falloir investir dans leurs plans
de la ville puis planter de la vigne
vous savez ça coûte cher voire ceux en
plantes et il faut soigner une plante
qui ne produit aucun jeu raisin pour
deux trois ans quatre ans cinq ans avant
qu'on a une bonne production de cette
plante là les virus sont propagées par
des insectes par des nématodes ou encore
lors du greffage d'une bouture sur un
pied de vigne
aral tient lui affirme que le virus de
la tâche rouge s'est développée sur des
plants achetés chez son pays ni rist
établi à niagara on the lake valtech est
le plus grand producteur de vignes au
canada
cette année il a distribué plus de 3
millions de pieds de vignes d'un océan à
l'autre
l'effervescence allait elle est surtout
le canada est pas pas seulement au
québec même si elle est beaucoup au
québec la différence essentielle par
rapport aux autres provinces et que le
québec ça s'est développé très vite
c'est vrai que ça nous met au niveau de
la production un peu sur des charbons
ardents parce qu'on a du mal
effectivement à suivre à la demande
ici les vignes importé d'allemagne de
france sont soumises à un traitement à
l'eau chaude pour les prémunir contre
deux types de virus
mais pour la majorité des vignes celles
qui sont greffés et conditionné sur
place il n'y a pas de solution miracle
la certification son virus n est pas
possible techniquement et biologiquement
même si on fait en sorte d'avoir le
matériel végétal le plus sain possible
de le tester régulièrement les levi rose
les virus sont transmises par des
insectes et ces insectes là sont en
déplacement
valtech expérimente présentement des
solutions en attendant certains
vignerons freine les opérations et
denver l'a pris au sérieux
c'est la raison pour laquelle ont
ralenti notre note des nouvelles
plantations faut attendre que les vignes
soit certifié nombreuses
yvan quirion commandes lui aussi ses
planchers vannetais qu il ne se fait pas
d'illusion sur la présence d'éventuels
virus une évidence qu'on va en avoir et
quel pourcentage on souhaite le plus
faible possible
quel virus vous avez eu ici à là on a
tout eu et on a tout et tout le monde
tous ces plates le mais on est tous en
1995 5% des vignobles du québec était
atteinte du virus de l'enrôlement de la
vigne mais depuis aucune autre recherche
n'a été menée pour faire la queue devant
le fédéral investisse massivement
rapidement pour trouver des solutions à
soho et va falloir qu'on les règle parce
que l'on transmet le virus partout et
plus ample en plus au plasma ni virus
donc et il ya une jambe d'omerta là
dessus pour répondre à la crise qui se
profile le gouvernement fédéral finance
depuis juin dernier
certains tests de dépistage qui sont
réalisés à l'université brock de sainte
catherines en ontario
au canada nous n'avons eu que récemment
les outils permettant de détecter la
présence du virus dans les vignobles le
dépistage du virus se fait en
laboratoire
la technique utilisée permet de détecter
jusqu'à huit types de virus sur des
feuilles de vigne on détermine tout
d'abord si le taux d'infection dans le
vignoble visé est supérieure à 15%
quand l'infection des grappes dépasse un
certain seuil et les plus rentables de
remplacer la vigne malades tarp lancé
mou flows fiennes et la présence du
virus est inférieure à 0,1 pour cent les
scientifiques certifie que le vignoble
est sans virus mais ces tests coûte des
dizaines de milliers de dollars
seuls les pépiniéristes viticoles
peuvent s'en prévaloir
mais pas les vignerons
mamadou faye réclame plutôt un programme
obligatoire accessible à tous donc non
seulement faux programme de
certification mais au programme de
certification qui intègre quasiment
l'ensemble des producteurs canadiens
parce que si certains le font un goût de
l'effort porte ça sert pas à grand chose
où les insectes qui sont les vecteurs de
ces virus là ils font pas la différence
ample et les vignes donc ils vont aussi
bien dans les vignobles de mon voisin
aquatiques dans mon mignon donc si je
fais la foire comme mon voisin le fais
pas ça sert absolument à rien yvan curio
lui compense la présence de virus en
plantant davantage de vignes que
nécessaire on a besoin d'un directeur a
dit un électeur pour avoir un projet
d'affaires 100 tonnes par année
on va planter 15 6 ha ça coûte une
fortune
la perte économique c'est dans les
poches des vignerons des vigneronnes
s'imposer on peut pas refiler la facture
aux consommateurs pour prévenir une
catastrophe virale agriculture et
agroalimentaire canada tente de mettre
au point un outil plus performant que
celui utilisé en ontario une technologie
qui détecterait tous les virus
c'est d'avoir un outil qui permette de
les détecter d'abord une fois encore
parler des textes on est capable de
savoir quel type de virus pendant
lesquelles on devrait plus maire de
l'énergie pour contrôler leur
progression au québec
et cela va permettre dans le long terme
de lutter efficacement contre la suite
dans quatre ans à la fin du projet de
recherche qui vient tout juste de
débuter
[Musique]